hello and welcome to New World review
your source for everything full stop
no more joking this is new world review
and this is your source for everything
don't add too much salt to your meal but
add just a little more than you have now
yes oh and check that your beverage is
not too hot what you called comfy great
it's me Grand Line waifu here for
episode seven and six of your delicious
Hunter hunter fix before we get into the
episodes are reminded to hit those like
or dislike buttons if you're enjoying
what I'm doing it's actually an
amazingly helpful metric for me since
your wonderful comments are sometimes
spoilery so I have to get an overview
from Leah oh if there are any particular
themes or ideas you want me to address
do in fact comment and I'll get him to
tell me so it's in the back of my mind
more work for him it's great now warning
warning warning anime spoilers ahead
good episode 6 this was a hard episode
for me to connect with but we'll discuss
it because it's important to talk things
through and things get better when I
discuss episode 7 I promise I don't
really plan what I'm going to say I just
kind of spew out ideas and decide how I
feel at the end just this once I'll
break my ever onward reviewing style to
let you know things pick up next episode
so why did I struggle with this for a
start it was definitely the least
interesting episode of the series so far
there was no tension or at least the
tension was released so quickly I didn't
feel it we were reminded at the
beginning of the episode that Gahan was
excited and afraid about the experience
he had with Hisoka but that was the last
bit of tension from there it was a poor
imitation of food Wars though I have
been advised that this series predates
food was so maybe it's a mediocre
lead-up to food was instead it felt like
the world was definitely trying to make
an appearance for this episode and to
that I say thanks you tried you did it
now stop the world unfortunately just
isn't enough to keep my attention and
frankly it seems as though it wasn't
enough to keep Yoshihiro Togashi she's
attention either because not only was
the issue set up very quickly and
comparatively sloppily to my mind but it
was also resolved very quickly I didn't
have to think and if you've seen any of
the videos I've done on this series
you'll see a trend in my preference for
watching material I like to think I love
trying to understand relationships and
try to puzzle them out I like to try to
figure out why things are happening we
were handed them all we were handed them
all along with boobs don't think I miss
the boob
we all saw the boobs there was a boob
tastic close-up of the boobs by Leary
old guy I'm not entirely sure what age
group this is supposed to be for but
whoever it's for must love boobs
or be really missing them since there
are notably no women taking the exam
it felt really cliche to have a gourmet
hunter who was live and pretty while
having the big guy with her whose only
enjoyment was eating let's switch it
over and have the large woman in the
live guy live guy with boobs two women
maybe I don't know we've spent long
enough on that topic and I don't want
this channel blocked so onward I was
somewhat interested in Seth's
involvement with the exam once his phase
was done it seemed odd that he needed to
find a toll tree to climb and that he
was supposed to report to someone about
the quality of someone else's exam
especially if they've had been a problem
before
I admit I didn't understand the purpose
of the episode beyond introducing
another character to step on the heels
of another examiner one who enjoys the
aforementioned boobs and knows how to
gently reprimand someone who knows
exactly what they've done wrong and
deliberately did so it was a very
convenient way to bring yet another
character into the world but I felt sort
of blase about the whole thing
I enjoyed men she's passion for her
phase which became very clear even
before we were spoon fed the information
from sets I'm interested in the idea
that she wasn't considered worthy of
their attention and that someone tried
to attack her for it but I don't feel
like the world is ready for a feminist
take on Hunter hunter six episodes in so
I'm not about to go there if you do want
that I'm happy to oblige but I think I
need to see more than six episodes if
it's something you want let me know back
to men she though the fact that she
didn't move from her perch when someone
was leaping to attack her said one of
two things she was either really very
confident in her own ability or
incredibly confident in BO horrors
either way you look at it the you go
girl revealing nature of her outfit the
comfort with which she sat stood moved
and threw herself into a ravine I was
drawn to her and I enjoyed watching her
I wish there had been both more of her
and less of other people talking about
and describing her the show not tell
aspect of Hunter hunter is thus far
being the biggest draw for me and I
didn't like the way their own convention
was broken from ng I also understand
that bahara wasn't the main focus of the
episode he was there to back men'she up
and/or protect the candidate it's odd
that a hunter seemed to need two minders
especially when she began to get into
throwing knives in
badass way and jump into ravines to
demonstrate her ability Mahara was there
to prove a point as far as I can tell
but I don't know that he proved the
point they wanted him to prove I guess I
had a strong sense that men she could
have supported the episode all on her
own
I'm sure bahar features in the manga and
I know he was comic relief but the pig
crown was enough I don't want to hate on
bahara he was cute and entertaining but
he was also the cliche of an oaf I hope
he gets more than that because he
deserves it so does men'she I hope we
see them both again
let's leave the negativity behind though
episode 7 is where it's at y'all it had
everything I needed I was honestly
worried that I wouldn't want to watch
anymore if every episode from here on
out was going to be like sex to those
watching six then wondering whether it's
worth watching seven yes yes it is
artistically musically dialogue ich
liebe narrative Lea sonically it's like
they're two different shows we went back
to the single backdrop set up this time
in a ship from there I don't know where
to start so many characters so much
depth and intrigue so little time the
hunters we've met so far discussing exam
candidates was fascinating because they
dismissed all our current heroes I found
it particularly interesting that they
discussed Hisoka without mentioning gone
particularly when it came to the idea of
the ORA the fact that we're being told
about his circus aura shows that we have
a lot more to learn about the
card-throwing long nailed man because
there is something we can't feel through
the art and sound that the characters
are feeling and they go so far as to say
that that particular aura is very like
theirs which tells me a lot about
hunters and the kind of dangerous energy
you have to be projecting to be a hunter
but if they're feeling it about Hisoka
why not gone who Hisoka himself felt
kindred with is it possible especially
in the context of the rest of the
episode that God in kill was skills are
too advanced for these hunters to pick
up on are they overlooking the children
because their children are they still
too underdeveloped the children not the
adults it's something I'll spend at
least the next episode considering
unless it's clarified let's talk about
Notaro
despite being absurdly agile and quick
thinking for an old man he is so far
perhaps the most well-adjusted normal
person we've met overall since we left
meat up by which I mean his emotions and
the way they're shown to us are what
we'd expect from a normal person he has
ordinary amounts of empathy he's clear
and doesn't seem to want anything out of
the mental and physical stimulus from
whoever he can get to give it to him on
the journey like the ball he taunts gone
and
he'll allow if he's balanced which is
fantastic because it's the first time we
see kilo I'm not getting what he wants
and oh my oh my oh my was I've right
when I said I wanted to see what
happened when he didn't get his way we
have a dangerous assassin kid and that's
when I answer my own question about them
being underdeveloped sure they're kids
sure they're still learning but Notaro
himself sees kilwa skills is remarkable
we have a prodigious dangerous assassin
kid this is the first time we see
killers true power true abilities and
why he's capable of resisting poison I
find it fascinating that he says people
like him because they can never tell
whether he's telling the truth on and
we've gone on that one I don't think he
was told a lie since appearing on-screen
ascator bruh he doesn't need to people
tricked themselves into thinking he's
lying because that's the only way to
feel comfortable around this creepy kid
and that's another thing
creepy assassin kid is basically a
sleeper cell the hunters couldn't sense
his aura because he doesn't want them to
imagine having a small assassin at
school like actually imagine it for a
moment imagine he loses his temper or
lashes out at another kid because the
kid took his ball then imagine being
that kid after 14 or 15 of these
imaginary schools because we transfer
not deal with the issue in anime Kilwa
has to hide because he seems to want
social engagement and in absence of
another creepy kid he has to make do
with allowing people to think he's
constantly joking
I sense psychological issues y'all which
makes me wonder whether gun is the same
ultimately over the course of the
episode once he knows in the Tarot is
trying not to hurt him he abuses no
Terra's empathy to get what he wants
which is another ping in the sociopath
column for me he doesn't get the ball
but his intention is to make the man use
his arm and he does but only to protect
a child he wouldn't have done it for an
adult but gone looks innocent and cute
and energetic and that's endearing right
there's a lot to be said for Kiowa and
guns artwork really both can look
absurdly innocent but both are so
incredibly dangerous that the art is
almost painfully deceiving speaking of
art let's discuss art and music every
flashback or moment of contemplation has
its own flavor and I really appreciate
it when that's shown in the art his okay
has his original passion at flamenco and
his soft dark focus art style that
together create the deep intensity we've
come to associate but then so taht's
describes him and the sound and art
style change
sanely even in the real world giving us
a fisheye lens view that makes me wonder
whether it is the taut sphere of Hisoka
in that moment expecting Hisoka to bring
the Tower of cards crashing down or an
actual representation of him it's a
beautiful example of clear ambiguous
storytelling which makes no sense as a
sentence unless you've seen it yourself
that twenty seconds or so of Hisoka is
beautiful or ground it's also a great
example of the contrast between showing
not telling about men she's abilities
versus hisoka's go back and watch how
people talk about men she how her art is
drawn and you find there's nothing of
substance
we're just handed a potential minefield
of character defining moments for
reasons jumping to what I'm going to
call the basketball section of the
episode
Kiowas music is beautiful pensive and in
a minor key which makes me think of what
I said earlier about those psychological
issues for the first time the boy is
desperate to show his worth when a
challenge is issued what's remarkable
about this challenge is that it's issued
outside of the exam nothing in the exam
thus far has been a particular challenge
or of interest to Kiowa but now he's
found one finally something has caught
his eye and he's pushing towards it but
there's a little doubt in the back of
his mind and it's caught very well in
the strings of the music before the tech
light and art kick in to show how
powerful it seems power is blue as a
theme the color if you're seeing blue
you're probably seeing controlled power
that's the theory I'll run with until it
doesn't make sense anymore it sits well
with several moments in this episode
with Hisoka and Kiowa and gone beginning
to come round to the idea by the end but
by contrast gone is more commonly seen
with the green layers of instinct
perhaps the music involved in his first
attack is a beautiful almost improvised
percussive it was fun and irreverent and
the fact that he almost got an attack
off showed Gods major flaw one of them
anyway but he's used to being outside
put him in a room with a roof a normal
roof and you can almost take him out
maybe using his head will be the end of
him maybe he'll develop less springy
frog legs for now after one
underwhelming episode and another that
whelmed very nicely I'm going to keep
watching and see where this leads so
that's it for me if you enjoyed this
video in the content this channel
producers in general please do consider
donating to the New World review patreon
because the support of all of you
amazing people is what continues to make
this channel possible if patreon isn't
quite your
darling do please leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
then please do head over to the discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
re takes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on episode 6 & 7 of Hunter
hunter this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time
[Music]
buh-buh-buh-buh my voice sounds off now
I just hmm I don't like this at all